>>> TONIGHT, REGRETS, SHE HAS A
FEW.
JUST RELEASED TRANSCRIPTS FROM
THE JANUARY 6 SELECT COMMITTEE
REVEALING GINNI THOMAS, THE WIFE
OF CLARENCE THOMAS, SAID SHE
WOULD TAKE BACK THE TEXTS SHE
SENT TO WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS ABOUT TRYING
TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION SAYING
IN PART, QUOTE, I REGRET THE
TONE AND CONTEXT OF THESE TEXTS.
CONGRESSMAN SCHIFF THEN ASKING,
AND WHAT IN PARTICULAR DISTURBED
YOU IN HINDSIGHT ABOUT THE
CONTENT OF THE TEXTS?
TO WHICH SHE REPLIES, I WOULD
TAKE THEM ALL BACK IF I COULD
TODAY.
I'M NOT COMFORTABLE WITH ANY OF
THEM BEING -- I WISH I COULD
HAVE REWRITTEN THEM.
I WISH I DIDN'T SEND THEM.
PAULA REED IS OUT FRONT.
THOMAS REGRETS THE TONE AND
CONTENT OF HER TEXTS.
BUT SHE BELIEVES TRUMP'S GO-TO
LIE, THE 2020 ELECTION WAS
STOLEN?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
HER REMORSE ONLY GOES SO FAR.
WHEN INVESTIGATORS ON THIS
COMMITTEE REALLY PRESSED HER
ABOUT THE CONTENT OF THE TEXT
MESSAGES, WHICH WAS AMPLIFYING
AND PRESSING MEADOWS ON THE
FALSE CLAIMS OF VOTER FRAUD,
THOMAS DOUBLED DOWN.
SHE WAS PRESSED BY THE COMMITTEE
VICE CHAIRWOMAN, LIZ CHENEY
ASKED HER, YOU ARE AWARE THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS ALLIES BROUGHT
LEGAL CHALLENGES WHICH WAS THEIR
RIGHT TO DO BUT THAT THEY LOST
61 OUT OF 62 OF THE LEGAL
CHALLENGES?
THOMAS RESPONDS, I BELIEVE THERE
WAS FRAUD AND IRREGULARITY AS
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS DO.
SHE HAS NO EVIDENCE OF THIS.
THAT WAS AS RECENTLY AS A FEW
MONTHS AGO.
SHE SAID THERE COULD BE EVIDENCE
TO BE UNEARTHED.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS THAT ARE BEING UNCOVERED.
I BELIEVE THERE WAS FRAUD AND
IRREGULARITY CONTRARY TO WHAT
YOU BELIEVE.
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS
RAISED BY THE EXCHANGES WITH THE
FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
WIFE OF A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
WAS PRESSING A TOP WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIAL TO TRY TO UNDERMINE
DEMOCRACY.
IT WAS SURPRISING THAT SHE WAS
NOT ASKED MANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
HER HUSBAND.
AS A SPOUSE, SHE DOES HAVE SOME
CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECTION.
SHE DID DISCLOSE THAT WHEN SHE
REFERRED IN HER EXCHANGE WITH
MEADOWS TO TALKING ABOUT ALL
THIS WITH HER BEST FRIEND THAT
SHE WAS LIKELY REFERRING TO HER
HUSBAND.
SHE INSISTS HER HUSBAND DIDN'T
KNOW SHE WAS TEXTING WITH
MEADOWS UNTIL HE READ ABOUT IT
IN THE PRESS.
>> MORE QUESTIONS TO ANSWER
THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, PAULA.
>>> JOHN DEAN, FORMER NIXON
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
JOHN, THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I ENJOY TALKING TO YOU.
LET'S TALK WITH GINNI THOMAS.
SHE DEFENDS -- SHE STILL DEFENDS
HER BELIEFS THAT SHE BELIEVES
THAT THE 2020 ELECTION WAS
STOLEN, WHICH IT WASN'T.
CAN SHE HAVE IT BOTH WAYS HERE?
>> WELL, WHEN I WENT THROUGH HER
TRANSCRIPT, I HAD THE IMPRESSION
SHE WAS EVASIVE.
SHE WASN'T REMORSEFUL IN GENERAL
ABOUT THE FACT THAT SHE HAD MADE
THESE COMMENTS AND SENT THESE
TEXTS OUT.
SHE WAS REGRETFUL THAT THEY HAD
GOTTEN -- THEY HAD BEEN RELEASED
AND BECAME PUBLIC AND THAT SHE
ACCUSED OF COMMITTEE OF LEAKING
THEM BASICALLY JUST TO EMBARRASS
HER, WHICH WAS NOT THE CASE.
I THINK SHE REALLY WAS
UNCOMFORTABLE THROUGHOUT HER
TESTIMONY.
HER ATTORNEY TESTIFIED A LOT FOR
HER, WHICH I HAVE NEVER SEEN A
CHAIR LET HAPPEN AS OFTEN AS IT
DID IN THIS DEPOSITION.
IT'S AN ODD COLLECTION IN THIS
DEPOSITION.
>> PAULA MENTIONED THIS, THAT
GINNI THOMAS TESTIFIED THAT THE
BEST FRIEND SHE REFERENCED IN
THE TEXT EXCHANGE WITH MARK
MEADOWS WAS, INDEED, HER
HUSBAND, CLARENCE THOMAS, WHO IS
A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
WHAT DID THEY DISCUSS?
THOMAS SAYS, I WISH I COULD
REMEMBER.
NO SPECIFIC MEMORY HERE.
SEEMS TO REMEMBER SOME THINGS,
NOT OTHERS.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU.
IF SHE IS DISCUSSING ANY OF THIS
WITH THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICE,
WHAT ARE YOUR BIG CONCERNS?
>> SHE CLAIMED AT THE OUTSET OF
HER TESTIMONY IN A BRIEF
STATEMENT, THERE WAS AN IRONCLAD
RULE IN THE HOUSE THEY NEVER
TALKED ABOUT EACH OTHER'S
BUSINESS.
SHE WAS IN A POLITICAL LANE.
HER HUSBAND WAS IN THE LEGAL
LANE.
THOSE LANES DIDN'T CROSS.
IT WAS PRETTY HARD TO BELIEVE AS
THE TESTIMONY UNROLLED.
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THEIR
RELATIONSHIP -- ANYTHING IS
POSSIBLE, I SUPPOSE.
WHAT I TOOK AWAY FROM IT WAS
THAT THEY OFTEN TALK ABOUT THESE
THINGS.
THEY ARE SOUNDING BOARDS FOR
EACH OTHER, WHICH IS NATURAL IN
A MARRIAGE.
>> I KNOW YOU BELIEVE MARK
MEADOWS IS TARGET NUMBER TWO
AFTER DONALD TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP IS RIGHT NOW THE
ONLY REPUBLICAN RUNNING FOR THE
PRESIDENCY.
IS ANY OF THIS NEW REVELATIONS
FROM THESE TRANSCRIPTS ENOUGH TO
LOOSEN DONALD TRUMP'S GRIP ON
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> I DOUBT IT.
NOT IN HIS BASE.
HIS BASE WILL STAY WHERE THEY
ARE.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE FACTS.
THEY OFTEN IGNORE THEM.
THEY CERTAINLY DON'T READ 800
PAGE REPORTS ABOUT THEIR
PRESIDENT THAT ARE HIGHLY
CRITICAL OF WHAT HE DID AND
EXAMINE IT IN SOME DETAIL.
I THINK HE STILL HAS A VERY GOOD
SHOT AT WINNING THE NOMINATION.
THE POWERS THAT BE IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY ARE NOT GOING
TO BE VERY HAPPY WITH THAT.
AGAIN, THEY HAVE A BASE THAT IS
VERY PRO-TRUMP.
WE WILL HAVE TO SEE HOW THIS
STORY IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
UNFOLD OVER THE COMING MONTHS.
>> YOU WERE THERE WHEN NIXON
WENT THROUGH ALL THAT HE WENT
THROUGH.
IT CERTAINLY WAS NOT THE SAME,
WAS IT?
>> NO.
THIS IS WATERGATE ON STEROIDS.
IT REALLY IS.
IT'S UNRELENTING.
WE ARE GETTING INFORMATION FROM
MULTIPLE FIRE HOSES TH